the descendants three mystery trailer is
officially out and fans are more excited
than ever a whole world of new
information has been revealed and we're
ready to put some fan theories to the
test watch until the end to find out
what Mao meant when she said that spells
are made to be broken the new d3 mystery
trailer has revealed that our heroes are
in some serious trouble but they aren't
the only ones who need a helping hand
the whole kingdom of auradon is in peril
thanks to an impending sleep spell and
just when we thought things couldn't get
any worse then says the sceptre in the
Queen's crown of installing a newscaster
announces that it's unclear which
villain has perpetrated this evil spell
mal appears to be talking to Evie when
she says they are very short on time a
hole is formed in the barrier that
surrounds the Isle and Harry and Gil
managed to escape while Hades only
succeeds to get his head and hand
through the barrier Uma is once again in
the water outside of the Isle splashing
around in her half octopus form then we
see that Ben has gone full beast when he
lets out a scary roar now loses her
powers and we learned that the only
thing more powerful than maleficent
scepter is Hades as ember caelius stands
with a menacing pose as her tarot cards
cascade down all around her now seems
very distraught looking at a group of
stone figures and the title cards read
spells are made to be broken so what
does it all mean
let's explore the many possibilities
that are lurking beneath the trailer
surface in Disney's Sleeping Beauty
flora fauna and Merryweather decide it's
best to cast a sleep spell on the whole
kingdom and tell Aurora is awakened so
could the sleep spell be protecting the
people of Arad on the trailer shows that
audrey is sleeping in a chamber bed with
her grandmother by her side while hades
looms over her waving his blue Ember
maybe Audrey goes to the Museum of
cultural history pricks her finger on
the same spinning wheel and falls into a
deep sleep just as her mother did all
those years ago so it could be fairy
godmother who cast the sleep spell on
the entire kingdom until Audrey can be
awakened
but before Audrey's grandmother falls
asleep she makes a deal with Hades
we'll explore this theory a bit later on
in this video there's an even bigger
mystery from the trailer who is turning
everyone into stone is the stone statue
thing a side effects from the sleep
spell or is it a completely different
spell altogether maybe Hades has a
certain snake-haired relative who is
famous for turning people into stone
with her gaze for more on that theory
you'll have to watch our descendants
three true villain video it's unclear
whose voice is saying those ominous
words but we're not alone in thinking
that celia is the culprit so could the
Big Sleep be a result of a voodoo spell
or a Celia predicting the future if so
who is the great evil she speaks of
according to the trailer is someone who
wants revenge someone who wants to make
argon pay forever so who could it be
we've narrowed it down for four likely
candidates
it could be Hades Ouma and her crew
Audrey or Celia let's break down the
stories of each potential villain in
more detail from the previous
descendants three teaser we know that
Hades has been locked up for some
unknown reason you have to be pretty
evil to be locked up on the Isle where
literally everyone is a villain so what
did Hades do that caused his
incarceration
maybe dr. facile ear is the gatekeeper
after all he does have friends on the
other side who could have captured the
god of the underworld for him we're not
sure who freed Hades but let's say for
argument's sake that it was one of the
facile ears we believe Hades made some
sort of deal with the voodoo master to
bring him something in exchange for his
freedom but what was the deal we'll get
to that a bit later from the mystery
trailer we know that Hades manages to
get his head and arm through the hole in
the barrier on the Isle
he shoots some sort of magical blue
light forced out of his ember then mouse
as someone was draining all of her magic
and she felt her powers slipping away by
now most fans are sure that Hades his
mouths dad but if this is true why would
he be draining her powers could that be
a part of the deal he struck with dr.
Vasily R in exchange for his freedom
that may
part of it but we believe it goes even
deeper than that the tarot card at the
end shows a picture of Hades so he
certainly has a major role to play in d3
watch until the end to get the whole
theory okay can we just pause for a
minute and talk about Emma's new look it
is absolutely stunning
seriously we did not know a sea creature
could look so graceful in the water okay
back to our Ummah theory if you freeze
the mystery trailer you'll see that
Emma's necklace is glowing with the
yellow light that looks like the other
light that strikes the aisle later on in
the trailer we know that uma is
determined to destroy the barrier and
escape the aisle maybe she finds a way
to use her mom's shell necklace to blast
a hole in the barrier but after she
escapes with Harry and Gill Hades pushes
his way through it's unclear whether or
not uma and hades have teamed up but at
one point
uma is holding the blue ember which is
said to be even more powerful than
maleficent scepter
she looks pretty pleased with herself so
did omus steal it from Hades we can't
imagine him giving it up without a fight
we know that uma is fighting those
armored guards alongside the other V
Ches
so does she turn good and held mal fight
evil or as she as bad as ever from the
trailer we can see that Celia has got
her evil laugh perfected but in the
previous trailer threat to auradon she
is standing next to mal as they open a
big gate could she be trying to help now
or is she deceiving mal and leading her
into a trap in the new trailer if you
look closely you can see her in the
background behind the armored guards
with swords she is holding Carlos's dog
dude is she planning to kidnap him or is
she trying to protect him if she was
trying to save him it didn't work
because we see him as a stone figure at
the end of the trailer we'd like to
think that Celia is a good kid but her
evil laugh tells us otherwise
pictures of Audrey as a villain have
been circulating the Internet's for a
while now however the mystery trailer
showcases Audrey looking like a princess
with blonde hair so it's clear she
undergoes some sort of major
transformation in d3
we see her looking shocked about
something at the beginning of the
trailer then later
Audrey's asleep while Hades looms over
her with his blue amber
it looks like Hades is trying to awaken
Audrey from her slumber with her
grandmother sitting at her bedside
maybe her grandmother made a deal with
Hades that if he wakes her up she will
give him something in return
so Hades wakes up Audrey but then
captures her and takes her to dr. facile
ear where he shows her the card that
proves she really wishes to be mouth
doctor passively are then transformed
Audrey into an evil villain who steals
the Queen's crown and Maleficent scepter
one theory is that Audrey uses
Maleficent staff to cast The Big Sleep
spell but why would Audrey be asleep as
her suite and is himself in the trailer
there is a pink fog over all of the
sleeping subjects but that could just be
present to throw us off it's more likely
that Audrey pricks her finger on the
spinning wheel and falls asleep leading
very godmother to cast a sleep spell on
the whole kingdom but then fairy
godmother gets turned to stone before
she can wake everyone up then Hades
wakes up Audrey and dr. fassl ear turns
her into a villain we all knew that
there was a possibility that Ben would
turn into a beast one day just like his
father but what causes this
transformation maybe Audrey chooses to
turn Ben into a beast so she can get
revenge on him for choosing to be with
now Ben is in his human self at the
beginning of the mystery trailer when he
announces that the scepter and Crown had
been stolen it's highly likely that
Audrey used Maleficent scepter to make
then go full beast mode
maybe she thought mal wouldn't like him
anymore if he was a beast if that's the
case she needs to revisit the story of
Ben's parents we all know that it was
the love of Ben's mom that broke his
dad's curse changing him from his beasts
form back into his human form so all mal
would need to do is to change him back
to his human form to give him true
love's kiss
right Ben totally needs to be rescued
again and we know that mal is up for the
challenge
the title cards in the mystery trailer
read spells are made to be broken this
is a vague statement that has a lot of
meaning behind it which spells are they
referring to all of them that would mean
that the spell that created the barrier
around the aisle would be broken and
this rule of thumb would also apply to
the sleep spell but what other spells
could they be referring to it's possible
that Audrey really is good but is under
some sort of evil spell and we know that
evil Audrey is up to no good with
Maleficent scepter could the scepter be
responsible for turning people into
stone will she be casting spells that
Hades later breaks with his blue ember
or is it mal who rescues everyone with
the Ember now made it very clear that
the only way to overpower Maleficent
scepter was by acquiring Hades umber she
even went as far as saying that if she
failed to get this ember it would be
game over there is a chilling moment in
the trailer when mal is completely
devastated as she looks and sees that
her friends Jay Carlos evey Ben and even
dude the dog have been turned to stone
everything that is meaningful to mal is
taken from her in descendants 3 we know
that she loses her powers because she
says that she felt them being drained
from her
we're not sure who did the power
draining but it looks like it was Hades
now Rican acts with her dad but from the
look on his face when he sees her in the
trailer it doesn't look like a happy
reunion
he looks downright evil when we see him
holding the Ember in his hand
from the hair in the foreground we're
pretty sure he's looking at mal with
that evil glare in his eye was Hades
able to absorb a mouse magic so that he
could become the most powerful villain
on the Isle if so that means Hades can
take on the form of a dragon now that
would be really cool to see at the end
of the trailer we hear mouths voice
saying that unless she gets that ember
it's game over
so will now have to fight her own father
in order to get his umber and save
auradon and will she also be the one to
defeat Audrey that means she will have
to fight against her own mother's magic
scepter mal is going to have to form
alliances with old enemies like Ouma
Harry and Gil in order to pull this off
so what do you think of these mystery
trailer theories if you think mal is
going to
save our Don from evil leave a dragon
emoji in the comments and that's a wrap
give this video a big thumbs up if you
think dude the dog is the cutest and
don't forget to subscribe to the things
for the latest descendants news thanks
for watching we'll catch you next time
[Music]